let's jump into that first story from
just the news
capital breach
seven individuals some tied to comedian
colbert caught unapproved in complex let
me see if i can pull this twitter it
looks like we're getting like a weird
thing happening with the yeah
so here we go we got this uh this
twitter thread from chad pergram who
says
fox confirms that groups of persons
associated with the late show stephen
colbert were arrested uh last night and
charged with illegal entry to house
office buildings after hours fox is told
that people were arrested in the long
worth house office building the group
was in the cannon house office building
earlier in the day trying to get
interviews around the time of the one
six committee hearing however uscp
shooed them away because they did not
have proper press credentials however
the group the group surfaced later in
the night after the capital complex was
closed to the public fox is told they
took pictures and videos around the
offices of house minority leader kevin
mccarthy and lauren bobert
sounds like an insurrection if you were
to ask me i mean that's what the media
was saying about uh uh who was it was it
uh who was that who's the was the
congressman right there loudermilk
loudermilk very louder they were saying
he was leading a tour and helping people
or giving them insider information what
is this why would they why would they be
why would they take pictures they say
they were unescorted and arrested in
charge of the legal entry they were
arrested near beau bert's office
released overnight they've confirmed all
of their names nine people now i can
confirm
several of these people do work for
stephen colbert some of them i believe
which is uh
one of these guys i don't know is is the
voice of that comedian that dog that
robert smigiel is that who that is yes
what's the dog trying to try him yeah
yeah
oh he actually goes on to say that
uscp have issued the following statement
on june 16th 2022 at approximately 8 30
p.m u.s capitol police received a call
for a disturbance in the longworth house
office building responding officers
observed seven individuals unescorted
without congressional id in a floor
hallway the building was closed visitors
and these individuals were determined to
be part of a group that had been
directed by the uscp to leave the
building i got to tell you my friends
this is worse than january 6. how so you
think i'm joking i'm not joking i mean
that seriously on january 6 many of the
people who entered the building
walked up with no signs with nothing and
had the doors opened for them by the
police who then went to take selfies
with them
those people one guy so far because
there's been a few uh uh uh bench trials
one of these guys was acquitted
because the judge said
cops opened the door and let him in
that's not trespassing there was another
guy who tried claiming the same thing
but he's on video climbing through a
broken window and over broken vest sorry
that's not gonna fly you know you're
trespassing yeah these people were told
to leave
they came back
and according to uh uh i believe we have
a it was a tweet from jonathan turley
and the statement made by uh
it wasn't for jonathan turley tweeted
what jesse waters reported that it was
adam schiff and maybe one of the
staffers who let them in the building so
you have a member of congress letting
them letting them in the building after
they were told by the police not to be
there
that's almost as bad as the riders now
there wasn't they weren't engaging in
violence the writers on january 6
obviously you know arrest them and
charge them as appropriate but these
what they did is worse than what the
maga mimos did when they when they
blindly walked in confused so i'd like
to see several fbi raids uh maybe some
uh misdemeanor charges that result in a
year of solitary confinement uh what say
you good sir well let me ask you this
tim what do you think if let's say those
producers were reaching out to many
members of of the house trying to get in
uh to the the capital you know via
requests and stuff maybe adam schiff
wasn't the first one in fact a a source
from the house sent me an email from
jake plunkett sent on uh june 6th hi
reaching out on behalf of robert smeigle
in the triumph of the insult dog he'll
be in dc on june 15th and the 16th
covering the jan 6 hearings wants to do
some comedy bits with members of both
sides of the aisle if you haven't seen
triumph he's the insult comic dog and
with conan and recently had his own hulu
special we've done bits with everyone
from barney frank ted cruz and corey
booker we're very much interested in
doing comedy for both sides that's an
email that was sent on june 6th now if
adam schiff actually let these guys in
right there's a process i used to work
in the house and that in the long worth
building i worked there and in order for
you to get access to to the office
buildings as press you have to go
through the admin and get the the house
admin and get press credentials
the reason you would go to a member to
let you in is so that you're let in
without having to declare that you're
press right and so that's and not only
that can you bypass security well you
you can't you
i have to be registered in by the
somebody from the office of the of the
congress member so they they're you're
on record that you're in but there are
rules if you're a visitor to one of
these offices for a congress member
you're not allowed to even roam the
halls of the office building what about
after hours when the building's closed
definitely not because you need an offer
you need somebody a staff member of the
congress member who let you in to be
escorting you through the halls at all
times so my question is
if you were let in after hours is it
would that bypass it would you be able
to bypass security well adam schiff has
to answer
no you can't you somebody had to let him
in through the doors right then they let
him loose through the building what i
mean is
is there is there a way to open doors
for people that does not bring them
through any kind of security oh no no no
no everyone goes secure everybody goes
through that's what i want to make sure
yeah i'm like did they open a side door
and even after 7 p.m there's only one
door it's called the 24-hour entrance at
the longworth building there's only one
door you can get in after 7pm so you're
saying that he signed the men he brought
them through a staffer or himself had to
have signed him in wow and they were
there so uh on jesse waters apparently
they were like banging on doors and
yelling and that's how the cops were
alerted to it we need more reporting to
come out because this story is just
coming out now here's the crazy thing
this happened yesterday at 8 30 p.m what
how are we just now finding out about it
there's people in the chat room calling
this uh in soy erection
which i just wanted to note here and you
made a good point tim especially on
january 6th there was
doors that were extremely heavy that
were closed with magnets that were only
opened because of a code that was input
directly by someone from the inside that
knew the code that was able to open the
doors on january 6. what happened here
this video the cops opening the door and
the cop even says don't agree with it
but i respect it yeah yeah so so you
know
what happened here we don't know maybe
they're they're trying to do another big
pfizer
saying and uh
sang and dance routine uh trying to
promote more uh procedures who knows we
don't know we do need more reporting to
find out exactly what was going on here
it would be funny if all of those people
were dressed up like giant vaccinations
i don't know remember when you get
around running around i i think you guys
aren't taking this seriously enough it
sounds to me like adam schiff came
dangerously close to overthrowing the
united states government you're right
you're right we need hearings
immediately absolutely adam schiff i
mean let's be serious though
if it's true that he let them in i mean
that's way worse than january 6. donald
trump said peacefully march to the
capitol and and cheer on politicians
something like that were there
republican elected officials who let
people into the capital on january 6th
no yeah did any sign
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying this is
so look
the the the left will always try to
conflate all of january 6 with just the
right in on the one side of the building
i'm not talking about that those people
who are fighting with cops and smashing
stuff and hitting like those people will
get charged arrest them charge them yes
make sure it's appropriate you get what
you get
i'm not a fan of what they're doing with
the the solitary confinement for a year
anything that's that's egregious but if
you're if you're riding you get arrested
but there's videos of people just
walking up confused there's no fences
there's no barricades and then the cops
literally open the door and they wave to
people as they walk in with their flags
one cop stops they take a selfie
together and they're like yeah thank you
apparently one guy claimed that the cops
were actually like yeah come on in
there's actually video of cops fanning
people like this
now the argument there was the capitol
police said the cop was fanning the
police not the people well you got a
problem there if there's regular people
standing there confused and you're going
like this and motioning forward and
they're like okay yeah they think you're
telling them to come in that's also a
very strange excuse taking selfies with
insurrectionists is not really a good
look also hold on that that seems like a
ridiculous story so if there were people
who were just mobbing the compound right
and we're calling security over and
those people are at the door i'm not
going like this
to gesture security to come over to help
us right that's not how that works
that's insane that is such an insane
argument like you know i was just i was
just doing a general waving motion into
the building because i wanted one
specific person to stop everyone else
from getting in the building maybe what
happens just fine they were telling the
other officers to pull back so here's
okay well maybe i could see that but
here's a silly question the
january 6th in the january 6 event
insurrection is probably going to be one
of the most documented
events in american history
even now it's been what a year and a
half old yeah right
there's so much documentation on this
that there are dissertations that will
be written about people's dissertations
about people's opinions about what they
thought they saw whatever
has anybody and i mean anybody that has
the cogency
to ask
maybe somebody who knows anything about
security regarding security protocols
security operations i mean it's not a
complicated situation the whole fanning
thing is ridiculous we we need to get to
the bottom of the uh 529 insurrection
529 insurance 520 in all seriousness
that's right five nine well more roughly
two-thirds of americans want to look
into the 2020 riots according to polling
data
less than half want to look into january
6th less than half agree with the
january 6th commission you mean the 529
instructions yeah that's right the 529's
never forget
and i never are you familiar with 529
i live in minneapolis i'm familiar i
heard it was mostly peaceful 539 in
washington dc when violent leftists
tried tearing the fence down and set
fire to one of the white house guard
posts set fire to saint john's church
and forced the president to retreat to a
bunker attacked journalists and the
police had to come and defend the white
house from this insurrection on 5 29 5
29
yeah 529. i remember that
you mentioned
that they were this is one of the most
documented events and it is curious why
aren't they releasing the security
camera footage why not really solve the
security camera from 529 well from
january january 6th was more documented
but yeah both
and they won't or the federal
involvement and
exactly at least information about how
many agents uh you know were there and
more participating and and also you know
the foreknowledge with basic events that
were on facebook saying that this was
going to happen and then this was all
something that they had maybe
what about the supposed pipe bombs that
were just near where kamala harris was
that they decided to stop investigating
stop talking i have a real question um
after january 6 a bunch of leftists
started doxxing all of as many people as
they could posting their photos and
faces no one did that for 5 29 i mean
that seriously like on at the white
house you have all this video of people
trying to br break down the fence they
actually tore down the barricades they
actually set fire to one of the guard
posts and a church
the right is not playing this game i i
was gonna say as as a as an activist
i've seen this over and over again we're
just not willing to do what the left is
willing to do to take us out right
the sedition hunters page is what you're
talking about where they're going out
and doxing you know people who were part
of the insurrection or whatever but we
don't do that why not uh we we have this
i think that the right has a problem of
of actually just participate where the
space is available why don't we have our
own version of splc or adl that just
goes and labels people communists or you
know marxists or you know woke uh you
know
because because you know the way i see
it is like
the quote-unquote right is a is a
disparate group of random factions that
disagree with each other on so many
different things yeah not even
necessarily individualists i mean
conservatives are more individualists
but they're more collectivist than say
but
to be contrarian here is is that going
to be the right strategy because someone
did something bad should we do something
bad too and use the state and the
government and the deep states to go
after people politically so so i i
understand the paradigm i'm just playing
uh
it's not bad to call out bad people
right they're just duplicitous there is
right-wing uh media matters sort of i i
think it's unfair to say necessarily but
news busters you're familiar newspapers
so they they watch all of the all these
cable channels then call out the lies in
the media i respect that media matters
lies about people in the media so but
it's an inversion it's you know
i like what newsbusters does i don't
like what media matters does but at a
core they're both watching tv and then
publishing their their opinions on it
right so there is that counterpart
for the splc my whole thing is just
match them at the front i don't need you
to win just match them right because
then it opens up other
fronts in the war where we can actually
overtake them well right the thing is is
we just get we get we get kicked in too
much from too many angles but if you
look at the splc they they lie they
slander they've been sued successfully
by individuals that they they they lied
about they lied about me and they lied
about me too they took a speech that i
did and they took one particular
sentence that i said and they matched it
up with a sentence that i said later to
make it to make me sound like i was
calling for a revolution when i was
calling for an evolution and and and
people being better themselves
individually so so they're liars their
cheaters i don't think we should strive
to become what they are and and i know i
know where you're coming from i'm saying
no no one's saying that no no no but but
what you were saying i think was kind of
matched by that well i think that first
of all nobody would call
we call the splc liars right splc
wouldn't say what they're doing is lying
and there's nobody that comes out a
third party sort of a court of law dude
okay so if court of law did fine right
and
they committed the story they the story
they wrote there was with several
individuals including me they retracted
and apologized and corrected it and a
bunch of my friends end up on that list
too right but who has the
does everyone who gets put on that list
have the resources to be able to
challenge that right that that's the
problem thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you